Hello,大家好,我是不红。前天我更新了《红楼梦》第39回的内容,
也就是刘老老二性荣国府这一段。
然后在这个过程当中有一些书有朋友提出了一个问题,
就是家母跟刘老老第一次见面时的称呼问题。
然后我今天就就这个问题以及刘老老和经历王家之间的关系来做一个系统的一个书里。
然后我们现在打开《红楼梦》第39章,来看一下这一段。
具体就这一段,就是刘老老见到家母,
然后口里说,请老受心安,
然后更成本这里还有一段,
批语说,家母之后和其多一,
在诸人口中则约老太太,
在阿凤口中则约老祖宗,
在森尼口中则约老菩萨,
在刘老老口中则约老受心者,
确实有数人想去接家母,
难得如此,跪进其妙。
但是这个老受心,我们看的话多少是有点变扭了,
因为他紧接着,我们看到下面就是家母问刘老老今年多大年级,
刘老老立马说他今年75,
然后家母就说,比我大好几岁了,
也就是说家母的年龄其实比刘老老有小,
但是刘老老却叫家母是老受心,
这个说法我们其实是觉得稍微的有点变扭,
然后我们再看一下家母,
家母对刘老老的称呼是老庆家,
为什么家母说刘老老是自己的庆家呢,
这也是一个问题,对吧,
今天要把这个问题讲清的话,
我们就不得不把这个内容翻到红楼梦第六回,
也就是刘老老一进荣国府,
在这一段例,
我现在点开第六回的内容,
也就是这里,
刘老老之所以跟这个精灵王家有关系,
是因为他的女婿王狗儿,
他家曾跟精灵王家连过宗,
我们来看一下这一段,
就是说,
乃本地人是姓王,
组上曾做过小小的一个金官,
西医年与凤姐之祖王夫任之父认识,
因堪王家的势力便连了宗认作池儿,
那时只有王夫任之大兄凤姐之父,
与王夫任随在金中的,
只有此一门连宗之祖,
余者皆不认识,
然后还有下面这一段,
木金其族已故,
只有一个儿子叫王城,
然后王城并故只有其子小名狗儿,
然后狗儿生了一个儿子叫宝儿,
然后迪七流氏又生一女,
名换亲儿,
这就是这个柳老老的女婿,
他们家的一个家事的问题,
这当中有一个地方是非常值得注意的,
就是这一段,
当年王狗儿之祖跟精灵王家连宗,
那时只有王夫任之大兄,
也就是王夫任之大兄凤姐之父,
然后只有此一门连宗之祖,
余者皆不认识,
这一段内容非常重要,
比如之前就有读者问我说,
柳老老的女婿王狗儿跟精灵王家连的宗,
他后来打球方为什么打到了人家融国府,
融国府人家事情假的,
他为什么来人家假家要钱,
这个这里就分为两个原因,
第一个原因是什么,
是薛仪妈一家进融国府的时候,
当中是有一个前提的,
有一个前提就是薛仪妈一家本来是有回自己的娘家,
也就是精灵王家住的,
但是温德母旧王子腾生了旧生统治,
奉旨出都查边,
所以薛仪妈一家才没办法去那个精灵王家住,
然后投奔了自己的姐姐王夫人,
然后另一方面原因就是刚才第六回这里写到的说,
就是这一段,
说那时只有王夫任之大兄凤姐之父,
与王夫任,
与王夫任这四个字非常重要,
就是王夫任知道当年连了王狗而之祖,
他们家的这一一个宗,
然后其他人都不知道,
如果刘老老去精灵王家打秋风的话,
人家可能根本就不认识他,
只有王夫任知道,
所以他得来到融国府找王夫任打秋风,
这是一个很重要的前提,
我们再回到这个称呼声的问题,
为了帮助大家了解这个精灵王家,
以及刘老老的女婿,
他们一家人跟精灵王家的联宗关系,
我现在用平板对这个,
被分关系进行一个简单的罗列,
我们现在根据一张图来对比一下精灵王家
和刘老老的女婿王狗而这一枚,
他们之间的被分关系,
然后根据刚才我们看的红罗蒙第六回,
对两家联宗的盖树来看的话,
王狗而这一枚最初的那一代人,
我们将其称之为王家之祖,
然后王家之祖下面就是王城,
王城在往下就是王狗而,
也就是刘老老的女婿,
然后王狗而娶了妻子是刘世,
生下有两个孩子,
一个是亲儿,一个是把儿,
然后这就是王狗而他们家祖上这四代人,
然后我们再说一下他跟精灵王家联宗的一个情况,
然后第六回说的是王家之祖当初贪妥精灵王家的势力,
他认的是王夫认之父,
奉劲之祖,
因为是被认做旨而,
所以是所以精灵王家这一代人的话是比王家之祖要长一辈的,
也就是王夫认之父,
奉劲之祖,
王夫认之父的下一辈人自然就是王夫认,
他的女儿王夫认这一代人,
王夫认这一代人在往下就是奉劲这一代人,
这就是一个大概的关系网,
如果我们现在要把刘老老跟家母,
这两个人物填充到这个辈奋关系中的话,
刘老老的位置显然应该是在这里,
我们又红笔来进行一个标助,
刘老老是王狗而的岳母,
所以他的位置显然跟王承是一辈人,
岳母,
因为他是王夫认的婆婆,
所以他跟王夫认之父是一辈人,
他的位置应该在这里,
通过这一张关系网,
我们就能看出来一个非常奇妙的现象,
那就是王承刘老老还有奉劲,
他们三个人居然是一辈人,
他们三个是同辈人,
然后王夫认的辈分要比刘老老还高一辈,
加姆比刘老老的辈分要高两辈,
红老孟地39回的时候,
刘老老称呼加姆是老受行,
刘老老之所以称呼加姆是老受行,
一方面是出一对加姆的一个尊重,
然后另一方面的原因就是人家加姆的辈分
确实比他要高得多,
然后再说一下加姆对刘老老的称呼,
加姆之所以称呼刘老老是老庆价,
是因为从加姆的视角而言,
我们进行一个框选,
就目前这个框里的所有的人,
他们身上都有一个共同的标签,
那就是一个王子,
王狗儿的祖先跟王家连宗是隔了山路十八万的一个亲戚关系,
但只要连了中两个王家就合併到了一起,
至少从这个情侣上来说是这样的,
虽然实际过程当中王狗儿
这一买跟人家精灵王家根本就不粘编,
但是加姆从加姆的视角而言的话,
他们其实都是王家人,
所以刘老老在此刻就非常神奇的,
就像是王夫人的娘家人过来加姆这边做课一样,
加姆才会叫刘老老是老庆价,
当然了,从加姆以加姆的智商而言的话,
他肯定也能看出来刘老老其实跟精灵王家的关系很远,
但是加姆比较深通人情事故,
然后又比较可怜这些老人,
就是连平续老,
他知道刘老老肯定是关系没有那么硬,
但是出意一种尊重,
所以他还是把刘老老当王夫人那边的人来看待,
叫他老庆价,
这也就解释了红楼梦第六回,
就是刘老老一锦融国府的时候,
他对于王夫人跟鳳姐的称呼,
大家可以翻出去看一下,
就是刘老老对王夫人的称呼是孤太太,
然后刘老老对鳳姐的称呼是什么,
是孤奶奶,
这个奶奶两个字,
当然跟今天不一样了,
就比如红楼梦里面的话,
经常所有下人叫鳳姐都叫他连儿奶奶,
王夫人的话,
府上的人也都叫他太太,
关键就是这个孤子,
因为王家之祖认了人家王夫人之父,
被人家当成了旨二,
所以经临王家这边的女卷就带有了姑姑这个属性,
所以刘老老才会见到鳳姐叫他孤奶奶,
然后见到王夫人叫他孤太太,
这也跟家母称呼刘老老是老受星是一样的,
就是在这样一个复杂的一个亲戚关系里面,
大家通过自己的理解站在自己的视角,
然后对于人物的称呼做出了一个相对应的一个改变,
背后还有一个问题,
就是红楼梦的第42回的时候,
发生一件事就是大家争论的比较多的,
就是网上写红楼梦的时候,
很多人都会写到就是最后刘老老离开家府的时候,
家母给了刘老老几件衣裳,
还有一些单玩啦裤子点心之类的东西,
然后向王夫人跟王西奉他们俩对刘老老就非常大方,
按照原主里面的记载的话,
王西奉应该是给了刘老老八两营资,
然后王夫人给了刘老老师两代的营资,
一代里面是五十两,一共是一百两,
而且按照刘老老自己所数,
二十两营资就是普通金礁,
也就是京城附近的农村人家一年的花销才二十两,
然后王夫人一次性就给了一百两,
这是一个非常巨大的数目了,对他们来说,
之前经常会有读的,
说家母怎么这么小气,
然后王夫人怎么这么大方,
其实就是因为这种清楚关系所导致的,
刘老老来打秋方打的其实是王夫人,
并不是人家假家,
家母对刘老老只是一颗相带,
所以没必要给那么多钱,
王夫人跟王西奉他们两个都是王家人,
刘老老这次过来的话,
又是打着两个王家连踪的名义来的,
所以王夫人跟奉结,
对刘老老是非常的大方给了很多钱,
这是两个人给刘老老钱的一个情理逻辑,
这一点我们是一定要明白的,
然后这大概就是今天的一个小小的内容了,
我们把时常控制在十分钟左右就可以了,
那就今天的内容就到这里吧,
我们下个视频再见,